je vous parle aujourd'hui du futur
samsung galaxy s 22 des futurs samsung
galaxy s 22 parce qu'il devrait y avoir
pas moins de trois modèles comme on l'a
vu avec le s20 avec le s 21 hélas cette
année a priori avec le s20 de l'ehess 22
samsung galaxy s 22 galaxy s 22 + galaxy
s 22 ultra alors il ya plein de choses
extrêmement intéressante à voir dans
cette vidéo je vais vous parler de
choses qui sont avérées notamment ici le
nouveau processeur de samsung qui a été
annoncé c'est l'exynos 2200 cadre des
soirées newsroom de samsung c'est une
annonce qui est du 18 janvier donc
vraiment vraiment actuel ça savoir un
truc qui est extrêmement intéressant
parce qu'un très gros choix stratégiques
effet il ya un vrai truc qui va être
passionnant notamment pour le gaming sur
pc c'est une nouveauté c'est vraiment
vraiment intéressant et puis on va
regarder un peu à quoi devrait
ressembler ces samsung galaxy s 22 en
2022 bien évidemment plein de choses
très intéressantes qui sont en lien
notamment avec je pense la fin de la
gamme note qui a donné son teint et
smartphones en 2020 il n'y a pas eu de
gamme note en 2021 jeu portera plus de
gamme note en 2022 il ya une nouvelle
écriture au niveau du style et c'est ce
qu'on va regarder ici plein show super
cool que ce soit au niveau de l'écran au
niveau de la photo ad j'ai mes notes là
tout est là et ça c'est cool allez c'est
parti on y va
[Musique]
a été annoncée juste là cette nuit le
nouveau processeur de samsung c'est
l'exil aux 2200 alors si vous souvenez
on regarde quelques années en arrière
l'année dernière et l'année d'avant il
ya chaque année vous avez deux modèles
qui sortent de modèles différents au
niveau du même smartphone un modèle avec
un smartphone de qualcomm snapdragon
quel qu'il soit les 888 le huit gènes 1
avec bref on s'en fiche un smartphone un
processeur de qualcomm et puis de
l'autre côté vous avez le même
smartphone qui sort avec l'exynos on va
retrouver aux états unis et au canada le
smartphone avec le modèle de qualcomm et
puis dans le reste du monde on à l'exil
au sport je sais pas pourquoi c'est un
choix samedi avec qualcomm c'est comme
ça ok pourquoi pas et puis toutes les
années on avait l'habitude de voir un
processeur plus puissant du côté des usa
avec qualcomm et un processeur un tout
petit peu en dessous un tout petit peu
attention c'est quand même extrêmement
performant les hexagones un tout petit
peu en dessous et bien cette année ça
pourrait être différent pourquoi parce
que nous aurons annoncé un nouveau
processeur c'est l'exil aux 2000 sont
restés xenos 2100 il est super
intéressant pourquoi et bien tout
simplement parce que vous avez gpu ya
tout le côté graphique qui va être gérée
par amd rda de une architecture qu'on
retrouve au niveau des consoles au
niveau de l'automobile et au niveau des
pc donc une machine extrêmement
puissante pour tout ce qui va être
gaming et ça c'est super intéressant
alors vous avez tous le communiqué de
presse qui vous intéresse il est sûre
les nous room global de samsung il ya
plein de choses intéressantes à regarder
on va notamment et bien qu'il ya ce gpu
qui est fait en partenariat avec amd ça
c'est vraiment vraiment super bien on
voit également qu'il ya un upgrade au
niveau de ce qu'on appellera le npa qui
est le moral processing unit c'est ce
qui va gérer l'intelligence artificielle
ça monte aussi plein de choses vachement
intéressante au niveau de la photo au
niveau de l'écran alors attendez je vais
vous montrer au niveau de l'écran à
l'épargnant touquet supra intéressant on
voit qu'on peut monter jusqu'à un taux
de rafraîchissement de 144 hertz alors
ça veut pas dire toute la gamme on va
avoir de 144 hertz en tout cas moi ce
que j'imagine c'est que je pourrais me
retrouver avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz sur le s
22 et es22 plus mais pourquoi pas sur le
s 22 ultra avoir entouré fléchissement
qui va en 144 hertz alors ça va un petit
peu à l'opposé de ce que disent les
rumeurs les rumeurs disent que sur le s
ventes le s bahn de plus on aurait un
taux de rafraîchissement de 120 hertz
non adaptatif c'est à dire que ce serait
soit du 120 hertz sur les 60 hertz comme
notamment sur le samsung galaxy s 21 et
feu tandis que sur le modèle ultra on
aurait dû s'en versent adaptatif c'est à
dire qu'il choisirait automatiquement 60
120 90 même un air sur du all ways
indices plaident donc ça serait
intéressant à voir tout cas moi j'en ai
vraiment je sais pas si ça va arriver
mais j'aimerais vraiment collé du 144
hertz sur ce modèle ultra ça serait
vachement bien on voit également que on
va pouvoir avoir au niveau de la photo
est bien en prendre jusqu'à 200
mégapixels grâce à ce processeur ça veut
pas dire pour autant qu'on aura un
capteur de 200 mégapixels on aura a
priori un capteur de 100 8 mégapixels au
niveau du ultra comme ce qu'on avait
l'année dernière garde et hop je
voudrais noter juste là et on peut bien
filmer avec deux caméras simultanément
en 64 mégapixels et en 36 mégapixels
donc ça c'est plutôt intéressant on veut
on peut faire également de la vidéo en
cas de cash des roues en 8k au niveau de
la résolution alors si on regarde ici et
bien votre smart ou de pouvoir venir
lire des vidéos en 4k jusqu'à 240 images
par seconde et en lui cachant à 60
images par secondes vous allez partir en
col et donc créer de la vidéos en 4k à
120 images par seconde et en 8k jusqu'à
30 images par seconde un peu ce qu'on
avait déjà l'année dernière donc ça
c'est assez intéressant un processeur
tegra vais en 4 nanomètres comme le
nouveau stade dragon huit gènes 1 cette
finesse de gravure permettra de gagner
en énergie donc un smartphone moins
énergivore donc une meilleure autonomie
et puis bien évidemment beaucoup plus de
performance derrière alors meilleure
autonomie oui c'est intéressant c'était
la raison pour laquelle il serait venu
diminuer la taille de la batterie alors
aurait vraiment dans les rumeurs là sur
le s 22 on pourra avoir une batterie de
trois mille sept cent millions terreur
sur le s 22 plus calmes et 500 millions
par an nous regardaient toujours une
très grosse batterie sur le s 22 ultra à
5 millions terreur alors ça c'est
vachement intéressant et pourquoi et
bien parce qu'on nous annonce rumeurs
toujours présent dans les rumeurs mais
j'y crois à c est bien un écran
extrêmement lumineux du côté du s22
ultra on nous annonce un pic à 1759 ce
qui n'est pas rien ce qui est énorme sa
vie avec votre smartphone en plein jour
vous verriez extrêmement bien mais plus
vous allez monter la luminosité d'une
dalle et plus vous allez consommer donc
c'est cool qu'on puisse avoir un
processeur peut permettre de consommer
moins de garder la même taille de
batteries qu'un écran plus lumineux on
pourrait potentiellement avoir la même
autonomie on verra ça lors des tests ses
smartphones devraient potentiellement
annoncé le 8 février prochain donc dès
maintenant à venir vous abonner si ce
n'est pas déjà le cas vous cliquez sur
le bouton rouge vous actionnez la cloche
pour notifier dès qu une prochaine vidéo
arrivera alors puisqu'on est sur les
écrans on va y rester on devrait avoir
cette année comme l'année dernière une
dalle dynamique amoled 2 x c'est l'impôt
retrouve sur les samsung galaxy s 21 et
feu on aurait des diagonales d'écran qui
serait un peu plus petit parce qu'on
avait ri dernière sur le s 22 en or une
diagonale de 6 0 6 pouces on serait sur
une résolution full hd sur le f 22 on se
réjouit de 6 55 pouces également du full
hd tandis que sur le s 22 ultra on
serait sûr du 6,8 plus exactement la
même taille qu'on avait une dernière et
ceux de résolution qhd plus alors il ya
un autre truc qu'on apprend au travers
de ce nouveau processeur qui va sortir
du côté de chez samsung qui est déjà en
production de masse en ils nous l'ont
écrit juste en bas regardez c'est écrit
tac tac tac tac tac is currently in
maspoli chez nous ça veut dire qu'il est
déjà en train de fabriquer au niveau des
productions match donc il va arriver
très bientôt et bien vous avez un truc
est vachement intéressant vous avez une
techno c'est celle-là ce qui s'appellera
le racing alors je vous passe un petit
peu le truc technique vous permettra de
simuler des conditions de lumière comme
vous les auriez dans la vraie vie donc
ça veut dire jeu plus immersif on se
croirait dans un monde réel donc ça qui
va être vachement intéressant c'est à
dire des capacités de calcul a cru un
gpu qui est sûre optimisé pour gaming et
ça permettra à ce smartphone si les
promesses sont tenues et bien d'avoir
une expérience assez inédite sur
smartphone en termes de gaming et ça
serait vachement bien il ya un très gros
plus parce que si vous souvenez si vous
le savez bien la gamme s de samsung
c'est une gamme qui orientaient photo
vidéo mais bien évidemment également
divertissement parce que le gaming c'est
un usage majeur qu'on retrouve
aujourd'hui au niveau des smartphones
quand on veut acheter un grand écran
quand on veut acheter par exemple un
style ultra green dalle de 6,8 pousse
ses énormes 6,8 pouces et bien on veut
ce qui se fait de mieux en terme
d'affichage on veut la meilleure
expérience et si ici il arrive grâce à
ce partenariat avec amd à être au-dessus
de qualcomm au niveau de l'affichage au
niveau graphique ça serait une très très
belle réussite une très très belle
revanche au niveau c'est processeur
exynos donc on regardera ça et on le
verra bien évidemment lors du test un
peu plus tard parce qu'ils finiront par
arriver et on testera et ça c'est la
bonne nouvelle en plus de ça ici on est
un modem 5 g paraît normal un modem 5 g
qui permettra d'aller jusqu'à 10
gigabits par seconde alors calmez vous
le dis j habib par seconde vous n'avez
pas eu votre opérateur mais en tout cas
c'est ce qu'on va nous annoncer ici avec
du soap 6 et des ondes millimétriques
ok et en même pas à pouvoir venir
utiliser de la 4g et de la 5g ok cool
alors qu'est ce qu'il raconte ce
smartphone d'un point de vue design et
bien regardez il ya des rendus il ya des
lic où j'ai pu récupérer sur internet et
on se retrouve vraiment avec un design
qui est très très très proches très
similaire des samsung galaxy s 21 de
l'année dernière le module photo
embarqué sur le côté sur les s 21 et
s-21 plus on doit vraiment la même chose
on retrouverait avec le petit point sont
l'écran infiniti au ici au niveau du dos
je vous lis sur les 21 et s 21 buts ce
serait la même chose mais on aura un
design a priori différents il ya
plusieurs rumeurs mais ça me paraît
assez intéressante au niveau du ultra
c'est à dire que vous avez uniquement
vos petits objectifs qui sortent ici
mais c'est tout pas plus pas moins alors
ça c'est intéressant aussi pourquoi
est-ce qu'on va regarder la config photo
alors tout est noté ici c'est ma feuille
et ben ouais je prends des notes sont
les galaxy s 22e semaine de plus vous
avez trois capteurs regardez vous le
voyez c'est ici à vous auriez trois
capteurs pourraient dans l'hypothétique
en premier s'inscrire grand-angle de 50
méga pixels on aura ensuite en ultra
grand-angle de 12 mégapixels et pour
finir avec un tel objectif de 12
mégapixels avec un zoom optique x 3
jusque là ça me paraît normal mais ce
qui serait intéressant c'est qu'a priori
ils pourraient une rumeur qui circule il
pourrait y avoir un partenariat avec
olympus au niveau de la fabrication des
optiques toi ça pourrait être chouette
on note chez huawei souvent via un
partenariat avec les cas on voit que
chez nous en plaçons un partenariat avec
un seul blake et là on aura un
partenariat avec olympus pour avoir de
très bonnes optique on verra ça bien
évidemment au plus tard ce sera
officialisé on verra si les rumeurs on
d'ivresse et pour le f 22 et f 22 plus
mais si vous arrivez sur le s 22 ultra
place un petit peu de choses vous auriez
un capteur principal de 100 8 mégapixels
comme vous avez une dernière sur le s 21
ultra mais probablement un capteur
nouvelle génération à mes deux autres
capturés encore plus de lumière à voir
on aurait en plus oui vous avez cinq
capteurs c'est quand même pas rien vous
auriez un ultra grand angle de 12
mégapixels mais là où c'est aussi
intéressant vous auriez un double
objectif 2 x 10 mégapixels premier
souscrit un x 3 optique elle deuxième
fois 10 optique dans les deux cas avec
un autofocus duel pixels et avec une
stabilisation optique de long terme de
photos on aurait un choix des possibles
on aurait une qualité assez dingue avoir
bien évidemment il peut se retrouver
avec une caméra de cette fille de 40
mégapixels sur le trajet pas d'infos
pour les s 20 es22 plus mais a priori ça
pourrait être une caméra 40 nega pixels
alors ici pas de caméras cachées sous
l'écran au niveau de la caméra de sa
fille c'est un peu dommage que c'est
vraiment la techno qu'on attend et on a
vu que ça me saoule que savait le faire
avec le galaxy z paul ii 3 mais il ya
deux choses qui a tablé ici la première
c'est qu'il dise qu'il n'aurait pas la
capacité de faire une production de
masse au niveau de la caméra sous
l'écran et on sait qu'ici c'est des
smartphones de masse donc ils vont en
vendre des quantités énormes même si les
modèles les plus vendus on reste dans la
gamme a notamment au niveau du à 52 et
puis probablement dû à 53 cette année
mais ça on en parlera dans la deuxième
partie de l'année et puis le deuxième
point c'est qu'on a vu sur le samsung
galaxy z paul ii 3 la technologie n'est
pas prête c'est à dire qu'on avait une
caméra de 4 mégapixels qui était pas mal
pour venir faire un peu de
visioconférence mais pour venir faire
des photos en selle fillon n'était pas
du tout donc je ne sais pas aujourd'hui
en tout cas ces six mois après la
technologie a évolué la technologie epr
est notre cahier quatre mois s'était pas
d'agde on peut aussi être une
explication regarder elle envoie un peu
les specs qui serait attendu sur le
modèle ultra on reprend ici à l'ultra
grand ton 12 ok on voit ça c'est tout ce
que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure le
processeur exynos 2100 la mémoire
honorée soit 8 soit 12 giga de ram est
en capacité de stockage 128 256 ou 512
j'ai même lu qu a priori sur le ultra on
pourrait avoir un terrain de stockage ça
serait cool avoir après le prix serait
quand même relativement et les batteries
de 5 millions d'heures on voit qu'on
aurait quatre couleurs disponibles au
global donc ça veut pas dire qu'on
devrait les quatre couleurs en france le
noir le blanc un verre et puis un petit
un petit violine sympa la petite caméra
ici là l'entrée sur le s 22 avec l'écran
de 6,1 pouces full hd + et des mickeys
mollet 2x on voit là un petit peu ce que
ce que ça nous raconte alors regardez
j'ai trouvé autre chose quelques petites
photos qui ont été publiées alors est ce
que ce sont des vraies photos ça semble
être vrai parce que on voit bien
regardez là tous les reflets qu'on a ici
donc a priori ces smartphones serait
comme ça avec un dos en verre de tous
les côtés même sur le f 22 est sûre le
ultra eh bien voyez on aurait a priori
un côté matt d'eau vers matt ça pourrait
être sympa là c'est pareil à quelques
petits lits que j'ai pu vous trouvez en
plus au niveau du ultra alors est-ce
qu'il fasse mon bien et vous le voyez
ici au niveau des ultras vous auriez
respect d'intégrer comme dans les
smartphones de la gamme note comme dans
le no devaient-ils note 20 ultra surtout
dans notre vin ultra est ce qui est
super intéressant ce que ça donne quoi
on a vu que cette gamme d'hôtels était
terminée je ne pense pas que ça me
saoule puisse revenir en 2022 avec un
autre genre pas de sens aujourd'hui la
productivité parce que c'était vraiment
lui dit de la gamme note c'est la
productivité principalement pour l'heure
trouverez ici au niveau du s22 ultra
donc vous auriez comme un grand note 20
ultra avec votre stylet intégré avec
votre espèce intégré avec les herbes
gesture et pourrait se connecter en
bluetooth à me paraît complètement
logique donc ici en fait votre s22
ultrahd ça serait un autre vin ultra
très clairement et vont trouver
également de la productivité au travers
de votre cette folle de troie qui est
compatible avec un s pen alors à voir si
sur un z folle de 4 pourra venir
intégrer ranger son style indirectement
ce qui serait d'ailleurs logique ce tour
un vrai sens en tout cas ici ça semble
l'être toutes les rumeurs convergent là
dessus on devrait donc deux types de
produits vraiment différent s22 es22
plus ce serait la taille de l'écran et
de la batterie qui voudrait vraiment
surtout changé ici parce que ce serait
la même config au niveau de l'écran on
et vous la techno d'écran et au niveau
de la photo tandis que l'ultra serait
vraiment à part au niveau de la photo
surtout le fait d'abord un aspect dit si
tu regardes et là on a quelques petits
rendu avec le spl ça c'est sympa ça
c'est des rangs du bon ça c'est rigolo
ce qu'on voit c'est qu'ici a priori sur
le f-22 ultra en aurait un écran incurvé
tandis que sur le f 22 et f 22 plus les
écrans seraient plat là c'est pareil ce
sont des des fuites on voit bien le
petit point sont ici haut niveau à des
écrans et on l'a également ici sur le
ultra on voit bien les écrans plats sur
le s 22 s 22 plus tandis que sur le lte
renvoie bien l'écran incurvé sur le côté
et la voyez c'est encore un autre
document qui est intéressant au niveau
des caméras au niveau du module photo
alors ça c'est encore un petit peu
différent on voit qu'ici on a bien sûr
le s wendel us 22 + 3 capteurs et ici on
en aurait effectivement 4 sauf que là de
ce convoi est bien nourri un seul module
photo et non pas des petits objectifs
séparés au niveau du dos de votre
smartphone en tout cas la configuration
son maître sensiblement la même donc on
regardera ça et c'est très intéressant
côté logiciel on pourra bien évidemment
sans surprise survenu à 4.0 basé sur
l'android 12 d'ailleurs je vous ai fait
une vidéo pour vous en parler vous
donner quelques astuces et vous montrer
qu'elles étaient les grandes nouveautés
si vous l'avez pas vu vous invite à
aller la voir je vous mets le lien
quelque part par là ou alors dans la
description et puis un autre qui serait
vraiment intéressant c'est qu'au niveau
de la batterie on aurait une recharge
plus rapide on avait les dernières une
recharge 25 watts maximale mais quand on
voit que la concurrence à décharge 65
fois ça fait un petit moment du vote et
yoann pleuvent on arrive jusqu'à 220 roi
du côté de chez chuo mis ça paraîtrait
logique que samsung ait augmenté sa
charge alors on sait qu'aujourd'hui il
vaut mieux charger un smartphone pas
trop vie pour venir protéger la batterie
et même quand on a une charge 120 watts
comme schumi est bien on a une charge
sont à droite pendant 20 secondes et
après on des 160 watts et puis après on
redescend tout doucement jusqu'à arriver
au 80 et après on descend encore donc
ici même si on avait une charge mais
bien de 45 watts qu'on pourrait
potentiellement attendre on aura 45
watts en pic et après on descendrait sur
du 23 août pour dire avoir une charge un
peu plus loin pour venir au tgp la
batterie pour smartphones en tout cas
d'un point de vue marketing ça aurait
vraiment un sens que samsung annonce en
tout cas une recharge un peu plus rapide
voilà pour tout ce que j'avais à vous
dire aujourd'hui sur le portrait robot
de ces nouveaux samsung galaxy s 22s
22h22 plus as 22 ultra on se bat
vraiment sur des faits au niveau du
nouveau processeur exynos de 1200 voix
ce qu'il est capable de faire on va
encore voir beaucoup de performances on
va pour une deming ça va être
complètement dingue pour la photo on
aura de la performance derrière bien
évidemment en terme de calcul aux
niveaux du cp au niveau du gpu au niveau
du npd avec de l'intelligence
artificielle ça va être vachement bien
les promesses regarde est vraiment
vraiment vraiment alléchante a priori on
devrait en parler début février 2022 je
vous invite bien évidemment à bien vous
abonner s'est pas déjà le cas comme ça
vous saurez tout sur ces nouveaux
samsung galaxy s 22 on en reparle
bientôt d'ici là si vous avez des
questions interrogations des idées des
suggestions pour démarquer en bas en
commentaire je fais de gros bisous deux
rendez vous très bientôt et que tu dois
parler tech bien évidemment
[Musique]
aïe